évidemment j'ai vu la performance
incroyable de ma mode ou kassaman un
jeune malien en france depuis septembre
2017 qui a sauvé un enfant laissé sans
surveillance par ses parents est
suspendu à son balcon on va revoir
l'extrait la vidéo est impressionnante
il a mis trente secondes pour monter et
la vidéo a déjà fait plus de 5 millions
de vues il sera avec nous dans un
instant avec son cousin les gars y'a
nous voir regardez
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma bulle
mamadou diarra s'est inversée
merci de nous faire l'honneur d'être
avec lui ce soir si fou vous avez 22
dans votre originaire du mali vous avez
quitté le mali en 2013
vous êtes passé par le niger le burkina
faso la libye et ensuite vous avez pris
un bateau jusqu'en france
et hier il se passe cette chose
incroyable et c'est vrai que depuis
vous êtes le garçon qui fait le plus de
plateaux télé en france c'est incroyable
ça va vous avez passé une journée
formidable racontez-nous juste cette
journée vous avez vous avez vu le
président de la république vous étiez
allé à l'elysée aujourd'hui oui
aujourd'hui oui je suis c'est un cc
foule alors si vous êtes venu et que
votre frère 1 voilà est cette fois
vraiment votre vie a changé depuis hier
parce que vous n'aviez pas vos papiers
vous avez vos papiers aujourd'hui ça
vous voulez conquis c'est çà et là vous
passez donc dans la rue
et qu'est-ce qui ce que vous vous dites
à ce moment là quand vous voyez un
enfant vous dit tout de suite je vais je
vais intervenir
bon j'avais chanté avec moi comme une
vous étiez ma copine d'accord voilà
voulait aller regarder les moitiés de
finale de ligue des champions étaient
sûrs s'est vite bravo
et est donc est donc là votre fiancée
qui vous a dit qu'elle se passe et ce au
nom non on a rentré sur l'aigle est
comme vous on a commandé des magies
voilà donc causé beaucoup d'émoi
n'utilisons entre l'écuyer les boissons
et les voitures étant donné qu
l'actionner oui bon je suis sorti j'ai
vu un enfant de 4 ans voulait c'était
sûr au balcon et voilà là moi je me suis
fondu de traverser la route fonds
mondiaux c'est fou parce que est parce
que heureusement qu'il est tombé sur
vous parce que c'est maxime gainey qui
passe par là c'est vrai c'est incroyable
vous faites fait qu'en fait vous fait
beaucoup de sport vous êtes vous effet
l'esports de passer à la salle des
sports
chaque moitié va l'aider souvent comme
ça les immeubles non non c'est comme ça
vous êtes dit j'y vais à la suite d une
incroyable
c'est fou alors ça fait beaucoup de
bruit donc jusqu'à l'elysée où notre
président nous a reçus regarde des gars
leur vie moi j'ai dit ce que je voulais
qu'ils étaient sourcing et 4 étaient
donc les directives manger des dîners
pas passionné des mois mais il me
secours il est en route pour un zombie
il était comment le petit quand vous
l'avez bon il en train de pleurer il est
blessé encore des sons puis voilà
blesson et vous l'avez revue questions
là on voit le voisin juste à côté
il n'a rien pu faire en fait le voisin à
côté est ce que c'est vrai que dans la
vidéo c'est apparemment il tient là une
année mais pas une ferme on verra c'est
ça et donc il fallait que vous allez au
moins dans cette vidéo c'est ici c'est
incroyable oui mais je savoir si
l'enfant il se tenait avec les demain où
il était accroché avec un mec demain
demain c'est incroyable cette histoire
c'est fou oui valérie ya le porte parole
des sapeurs pompiers de paris qui dit
déjà que vous faites partie des leurs
que vous avez les valeurs des sapeurs
pompiers de paris
je situe dit il à il a clairement les
valeurs qu'il faut pour rejoindre les
pompiers à savoir l'altruisme
l'efficience il possède toutes les
aptitudes nécessaires
par son geste accompli il est déjà l'un
des nôtres et il a vraiment raison parce
que vous êtes déjà un pompier quoi
[Musique]
mais comment vous avez appris vous vous
appelez ou bien vous avez entendu ça
elle a tellement il m'a appelé oui
c'était vers 17h 18h et on était
ensemble de montreuil d'accord ont sévi
bon moi je rentrais chez moi tout à
l'air et l'eau et il m'a dit que non il
veut sortir et d'aller voir le match à
hyères bon d'accord les docks et beau à
la prochaine donc lui le parti moi qui
le fais avec mes amis j'en prenais pas
les mêmes hôtels falls a sommé j'ai
regardé j'ai dit mais square
il m'a dit mais je vais à la franqui
nécesité sur les méthodes n'ont que j'ai
sauvée mais nos qu'ils savaient qu'ils
la police et pour bien tu peux venir
aider mais dites moi si vous vite chez
il me dit mais c'est lary merci de
romans de nouvelles adresses s'appelle
apple et je connaissais syrie je peux
venir le temps que je prends la voiture
entre montreuil porte de bagnolet porta
village a été un bel embouteillage
non qu il ne sait pas comment je vais
conduire des arrivées le temps qu'ils
arrivent vers la chapelle et qui m'ont
dit non qu'il vaut mieux que vous faire
un demi tour d'aller vers l'hôpital
lariboisière vais regarder nord nos cous
et dubaï je connaissais avant d'arriver
là voyage hyper wade qui sont là bas
j'ai eu les pompiers et les policiers
ont dû partir après avait les brigades
des mineurs qui nous a téléphoné et des
confine à l'hôpital ils vont révéler
voir les niveaux par la justice à paris
on était là-bas vers une heure du matin
encore et nous nous a confirmé que les
papas c'est un bon papa mais ça un
incident qui dans la rue ça vous les
appelez les parents n'est rien non nous
arriver sont échangé avec eux j'ai son
père en auditionnant ben voilà il a venu
me saluer qu'est ce que vous allez
manger salle y est c'est fini
d'accord c'est salué et aurait que vous
embrasser à un mot doux aujourd'hui vous
êtes un héros
est ce que vous arrivez à réaliser ça
c'est vous le héros vous avez sauvé
quelqu'un c'est un héros ça va changer
votre vie à tout jamais fois qu'il n'a
pas envie de te répondre
gilles à dire qu'ils sont de gentilles
ce qui réjouit si tout le monde sait
qu'on a tellement souvent l'habitude
d'entendre parler de sans papiers
d'immigration en termes de chiffres de
statistique que lacan s'attache à un
homme qu'on voit ce qu'on est capable de
faire quand on est comme ça alors qu'on
n'a aucun intérêt à faire je vous ça
redonne espoir et j'espère ça fera
changer certaines mentalités qu'on a
tendance à critiquer les gens qui
connaissent pas qui sont pourtant
fantastique qu'on les connaît